Vincent Oshana ladies and gentlemen come
on record I'm not gonna supply some time
I think the the ongoing joke we have is
the Hollywood handshake Hollywood
Hollywood they know each other like I
got bless your whole other name he was
so long boy hey hope y'all doing good
all right yeah so good news is the more
famous you get the less effort you could
be stinking at him yeah how long you
been doing stand-up man
seriously for about ten years and I just
I left the military to literally come
here and just do this because I love
making people laugh were you that guy in
the military I was that guy in the
military I got in trouble on the first
day on the military what I was me my boy
Jamal joined at the same time and I was
you don't say like did y'all dancing and
one of these stuff just caught me made
me come stand in the middle cuz we're
all in under whether it's making sure we
have no weapon the first day of the
military so he made me stand in a circle
of 100 dudes and he's like start dancing
right now and all these like don't just
go so um and I'm like running out of
stuff to do like these like to other do
other things so picture me I'm doing
this one and he told my boys like a new
cheer mon-sol picture me dancing like
this that my boys going go Vinny
so that was on the first day so I knew
that this is all gonna get kicked out
soon so now is not the place to be funny
they don't like that they get a little
bit oh yeah funny guys in the military
yeah well those are people want from
Russia with those people say yo you
gotta try it Benny you're funny as hell
yeah well the real inspiration was my
mom cuz you know growing up she was the
funniest one in our family yeah your
mom's support from day one from day one
well you know mothers are they're like
you're going to go there and there's
drugs in all way also yeah she's like
just be fun and cause she's she's
awesome she's my biggest number one
number one fan I can't get better than
that
yeah let's look at some early pictures
of my guy what I can my feeling the
pressure was victim dude the guy that
took this with obviously trying to have
sex with me yet yeah actually was like
he was like just undress me with your
eyes and I go I thought it was the
cameras like no no me Korean keep going
he will make it at the end of the day he
would make it and I got no clothes on
under here I got like this I love it
visit business a comedy headshot this is
this is for comedy already all right we
got on that guy very very funny guys
let's take a look at him and they show
you this
you